this woman like many others in her
suburb of cherniv feels forgotten
forgotten by her government
forgotten by the media
forgotten by aid agencies
she can't live in a home anymore she
tells us it was shelled last month by
russian artillery
nayla has no idea how to even tidy up
much less move back in
and says that towns like bucha and
european near the capital have received
aid help and attention while here
nothing
perhaps they don't know what happened
here i can't register the damage with
the government because i don't have
electricity or internet
if i could register perhaps they might
help but for now we just have to help
ourselves
the civil administration in chennai is
overwhelmed and so community groups have
stepped in to help
where once they sold cars they now
distribute food
and while this might look like a lot of
food it will be gone in a couple of
hours
leaving hundreds outside with nothing
this food distribution point operated
throughout the russian onslaught when
they had food they would open but more
often than not
they had nothing
today though is a good day they have at
least something to distribute
mostly people ask for bread and water
but water less now because they have
running water
canned food is in high demand in fact
anything edible they take thankfully
this man tells us his house was
flattened by russian tanks and no one
has come here to offer help
he trudges over the damage with no clue
where to even begin rebuilding
the russian president vladimir putin
insists that his forces aren't targeting
civilians or civilian infrastructure but
the evidence against that once again is
overwhelming and in this village across
a large area
and this is where some of the civilians
who were also killed are buried
the authorities had to clear part of the
woods to make space
these freshly dug graves all bear the
same months
march 2022 will be remembered even if
those who survived feel forgotten
imran khan al jazeera a suburb of
cherniv